[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George Campell joined by my good friend
Dr John deloney that's doctor with two
phds in case you're wondering and George
with two lindes in his one pair of
glasses that's all you need sorry I
don't know what to tell you John I know
how we doing I I couldn't spend my life
in Academia it just felt so grueling oh
yeah you should see on the other side of
it here you are now when you and I have
the same job we're both YouTubers jokes
on you man I showed you guys didn't I
well this is a this is a real treat John
uh it's been a fun week pre-launching my
new book Breaking Free from broke I'm
First Time author pre-launching yeah
you're launching well it's not launched
into the world yet but you can pre-order
it that's what I was trying to say you
can triple stamp a double stamp when it
comes to pre-selling this incredible
book dude yeah it's been fun the
response has been awesome and if people
are wondering what is this about
breaking free from broke how here's the
question I get how is this different
than The Total Money Makeover well The
Total Money Makeover has been around for
decades and I follow the principles in
the book and I lay out the baby steps
real quick but this is not the baby
steps rehash this is me unpacking the
financial industrial complex that is
keeping people broke and I had every
excuse and justification with a lot of
empathy and I want to talk at people uh
with people not at people and give them
the book that I wish I had when I was
you know in my 20s and now in my 30s are
going this is what people are really
dealing with here's how the system is
designed to keep you broke here's how to
get out and I did it and 10 million did
too there's the social proof and I I
think what's helpful about this that is
going to be helpful for me and and
honestly helpful for me and helpful for
it's a book I can hand to my son who's
13 who's just now entering into the the
the system right um they're already
going to start sending him in credit
card offers oh for sure already getting
you know college stuff all it's it's
it's a m it's a zoo but when Total Money
Makeover came out you had your
neighbors that guy had a nicer van you
know with like the wood on the side of
it and there was a guy at your church
who had a thing and then you had a buddy
who had a friend who was a banker that
said hey you need to get an adjustable
rate more CU that kind of thing
now it's coming at us a thousand
different directions all at the same
time you don't have real estate you
don't have passive income you don't have
crypto oh my gosh you're just putting
money in so much it's everywhere and I I
am an old man and I can't escape it and
so um we talked about the other night I
for those of you listening I'm count
myself pretty fortunate that I get to
sit by Dave you know hours a week and
he's somebody I call a buddy so if I'm
about to buy something or I'm thinking
through something I can just ask Dave
Ramsey which is pretty amazing and I've
also called George camel and like on his
cell phone when Dave didn't pick up he
was like I'll try George n Dave yeah we
don't I don't call Dave when he's on the
golf course but hey George help me walk
through this thing because I'm thinking
about doing this and if I move this over
here and so you're somebody that I trust
with my family's money and so I'm really
grateful to have this book in dealing
with the things that we're all dealing
with all at the same time right now it's
exciting man I appreciate that yeah I've
said that the the gap between Financial
stress and financial peace is littered
with myths and traps and distractions
and noise and I just wanted to cut
through all that and tell you the truth
and go in depth and hit every objection
that you've before you can even get to
it I just wanted to get there here yep I
hear you here's what the truth is about
money with tons of research with tons of
humor so I'm excited to get this book in
people's hands and help them break free
from broke and unchain and untether from
this broken Financial system and
deprogram and unplug from The Matrix so
if you want to check it out
you can go to ramsy solutions.com store
and pre-order today for just 20 bucks
and we're going to bribe you with $100
in free bonus items including access to
my newest talk show me the money
exclusive access to an online private
event in Q&A with me in January as well
as an enhanced audiobook John we're
doing a real fun uh produced version of
the audiobook and ebook you get that all
for free on top of three months of every
dollar premium for new users only so hey
that's not enough I don't know what when
does this when does actually hit the
store it hits the streets January 16th
January 16th okay we'll get the ebook to
you a few weeks early if you pre-order
as well so there it won't be there in
time for Christmas but it's worth
getting for folks for Christmas with a
little print out I was just thinking
um my book building an unex life that's
that's that might be hard to buy for
Christmas to be like hey uh I was
thinking about what I could get you and
well you're in good company John with a
book called breaking fre you're falling
apart so here you go but this is a book
that I could order and I could order 10
of them for all my cousins or all my
nephews or all my grandkids and there's
Christmas and I could have the little
card and and hand it to them and then
kind of When the Smoke Clears from
Christmas they're going to get it in the
mail a couple weeks later and they'll go
yeah all right new year new me yeah and
I think that's a I think I don't know
I'm just excited for it man I think it's
going to be I actually think it's a
great Christmas gift that will show up
right when all the Smoke Clear from
Christmas and people are holding those
credit card statements or they're in a
house and their parents are banging
their head against well why do we do it
again why' we do it again and you're 19
or 20 and you're heading back to college
this going to be perfect I appreciate
that man that's very kind well go check
it out at ramsy solutions.com
store I I guarantee you'll love it if
you don't I don't know that you can get
a refund but you can you can yell at me
on Twitter whatever you guys want to do
that's fine with me um but John before
we get to calls in the book I lay out a
lot of EX the things that people that
I've heard on this show when they call
in and they say but John what about
inflation and the housing market and the
cost of higher education in the fed and
did you see the guy in the White House
what he's doing and there's all kinds of
really good reasons as to why you can't
get ahead and why it's someone else's
problem and something I've been telling
myself and other people is that it's not
all your fault but it is your
responsibility and that I feel like
crosses over into your world because in
your new book building an on- anxious
life one of the choices you have to make
every day is choosing reality right and
that comes to a point where you have to
say there's a lot of things I can't
control and the one thing I can't
control is the guy in the mirror
and that means he's going to do
something about it he's not going to
wait around I get that question on my
show a lot like oh I'm supposed to just
sit down and tell my husband it's like
yes would you know how hard that's yes
but do you know how hard living your
life scared to come home is right you
know how how hard your life is um
struggling with nutrition and exercise
programs but I get it it's it's a matter
of choosing your heart so yeah for folks
like me who grew up with two parents who
are freaking amazing who love me but who
didn't have the tools and didn't have
the plan were just literally doing what
the the next right thing they were told
and I didn't have a plan um yeah it's
hard to suddenly submit yourself to a
plan that's not sexy and not shiny it's
way more fun and way more adventurous to
be like oh okay I got to get this in a
portfolio bro you have no portfolio
business you owe 40 Grand right or in my
case $100,000 to
you don't you don't need to be thinking
about passive income right so having a
plan like this is so rad and it comes
down to that choose your hard man you
can live a life where you can't breathe
and your body won't let you sleep
because you owe money or you can choose
your heart and say okay for 3 years I'm
going to work four jobs it's going to be
miserable it's going to be miserable and
on the back end haha suckers no one will
own me but me and that's that that's
where millions and millions and millions
ions of us are right now that's very
freeing yeah if you want margin if you
want options if you want peace in your
life you want freedom with your time and
your money you're going to have to work
for it and you're going to have to
bridge that gap between Financial stress
and financial peace and there's so many
myths and traps along the way so I
encourage you guys to check out my new
book Breaking Free from broke at ramsy
solutions.com
sstore I hope it helps as many people as
your books have John listen we say it
all the time nobody's coming for you and
it's easy to go what do we do now this
is the road map pick it up this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys being free to make your
own medical decisions is a big deal
these days Christian Healthcare
Ministries gives members the freedom to
choose the doctors and providers they
want without the frustration of worrying
about networks and with no waiting
period to join it's a membership-based
nonprofit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so see if chm could be right for
your family check out more today at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
this is your show America give us a call
at AA
5225 Tristan is up in Cleveland Ohio
Tristan welcome welcome to the
show hi I um recently had
319k and student loan debt forgiven whoa
I have about 33 I know right I have 30
how long dides that take I'm curious 10
years okay 10 years Public Service Long
forgiveness cool good for you so I
currently have about 33,000 in personal
debt me and my husband we had we
refinanced a family home we inherited
for about 50,000
and at this point I'm thinking about us
buying a new house running out our home
want to get you guys' thoughts on that
so you have this $33,000 personal debt
any other
debt no that's it how much money do you
guys have in the
bank uh about
22,000
okay so the question is how quickly can
we get rid of this debt and get an
emergency fund saved up before we jump
into this dream of home
ownership okay okay cuz that's my worri
is you go into this broke the house yeah
because it feels like you have 22 Grand
which I assume was going to be your down
payment um we we actually the down
payment would only be a total of like
15,000
total and what would the mortgage
be about 2,200 a month and that's on a
30-year yes okay what's your household
income household income is about 200,000
a year a personal is about 150 awesome
you guys have a great income so what is
the urgency to jump into the house
purchase right now versus waiting a year
from now when we've cleared the deck we
have no debt fully funded emergency fund
and a bigger down
payment I have a three-year-old he's
going to be turning four soon and we
live in a really bad neighborhood lots
of violence can we go rent in a better
neighborhood for a year while we do this
renting right now is going to still R
you about 1,800 a month you make
$200,000 here's how I know you can do
that because it's exactly what we did I
had a two and a three-year-old and we
lived in a residence hall full of
college students the smells are still
stuck in my nose and we weren't ready to
buy a house so we moved and we moved
into a 900t rent house was it fun no did
my wife cry yes did we end up having a
real down payment for a home a year
later absolutely
here's my worry Tristan is that if you
do this right now way next next year
around August I'll get like a lump sum
payment from incident that occurred
it'll it'll be about 25,000 awesome well
let's add that to the down payment
August of next year you'll be able to
put a big down payment
down I think you're you're itching to
get what was that on the skip out on the
$155,000 pay down payment option now
they're they're willing to take three
and a half% down of course they're
willing to please don't put three and a
half% down on your house please you make
too much money to be making broke people
decisions and My worry is if you
continue down this path 5 years from now
you're still going to be broke because
we never really cleaned up the mess or
changed our Behavior but we could fix
this really quickly I mean this is a
very solvable problem making 200 Grand
and you have 22 to throw at the debt
today so let's say you drain that down
to a th
within the next two paychecks you've
paid off your debt maybe four paychecks
after that six paychecks you have an
emergency fund now we can start saving
up for a down payment with no payments
in the world how much could you save up
a year
$100,000 because I think we
should I'm only bringing home about
7,000 a
month and because of what the
income it's just how much I actually
bring home I I make uh 142 a year but
I'm I'm bringing home about 7,000 a
month taxes do you have uh investment
contributions coming out uh yes
retirement and so forth um we have a
403b too okay so I would pause that
until we get this mess cleaned up
because that's going to free up a big
chunk of change for you isn't it if you
pause that contribution that's a good
idea that's a good idea so now we have
maybe $8,000 coming in every month who
knows or nine um and just you've heard
this story story before and I just want
to reiterate it because it's that you
hear the horror story and it's not a
horror story this is reality I bought a
house out in the country that was
completely redone from top to bottom and
it flew through the inspection and in
the four years since I bought it I've
had to replace the roof I've had to
replace an air conditioner I've had to
replace a hot water heater and I've had
to do some wiring issues because it's
out in the
country and so if you put
$115,000 down on for
3% and one thing goes wrong you're back
in the hole another 10 grand another 20
grand and so George and I aren't trying
to be mean or ruin Dash your hopes you
know what we're really trying to
do give some problems in the future well
we're just trying to give your baby the
greatest gift a parent can give their
kid which is a home full of Peace Not a
Home full of anxiousness because when
you have peace then you can hold your
kid accountable and you don't lose your
mind because you're you have no margin
when you have peace you and your husband
get in a spat which me and my wife do on
a semi daily basis and we both can
respond
rationally not emotionally because I'm
also I can't I haven't slept for two
weeks because I can't breathe about the
roof payment and the air conditioner
payment and the hot water heaters on the
fritz you see what I'm saying we're
trying to create peace in your home
that's the only way this country heals
is house by house by house and you make
200 Grand you have won the cosmic
Lottery if you will just take 18 months
and do this the right way you will
change your family tree forever and that
stress you have that is set your soul on
fire I got to get a house I got to get a
house got to get a house your kid will
never feel
that because it didn't grow up with that
chaos you see what I'm
saying all right I got to get out of
this day it's about hey this is about
freedom and not like uh um American flag
underuse this isn't like an Instagram
post this is nobody owns your home but
you do you think we should sell our
current home which still has about
100,000 left in equity you just told me
you're in a crimer riddled neighborhood
I would sell it and go rent for a while
and take whatever equity and pay off the
debt get the emergency fund and use that
for the down payment
fund yeah thank you guys JayZ said told
this if I'd be out of that neighborhood
I'd go but I'd rent a house until I can
afford it yeah okay thank you so much
you got it you're welcome trist yeah
again I I'm not beating up on Tristan I
just I'm looking at Future Tristan 15
years from now and I'm going they could
have a paid for house a couple of them
and be baby steps millionaires or they
could be paying on a mortgage for the
next 30 Years while hanging on to debt
and probably going further into other
types of debt because they bought a home
before they were ready which they have
car transmission fell out we got to get
another car and these aren't
hypotheticals that'll probably be the
next call on the show John exactly like
this isn't just well they're just being
eor we're telling you we're here to help
you guys when life happens when you
thought it was going to work out
perfectly and it didn't and we would not
have jobs if everybody's plan always
worked out the fact that it rarely works
out is why we're employed right
absolutely so Tristan when you're ready
to buy a home here's here's an easy
formula to know when you're actually
ready when you can have a mortgage
payment that's no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
rate mortgage which means it's probably
going to be 30% higher than that 30-year
payment but you know what if you do the
30-year payment before you're ready
you're going to stay broke a long time
and we found people that follow the baby
steps they end up paying off their
mortgages in about seven years and so
this whole like well I'll just do a 30
and I'll pay it off early or you go 30
years and then refinance and get a hel
loock on the second mortgage and you
just keep the debt ball in the air for
the rest of your life and you call us at
65 or 7 and say I still have a mortgage
I got all this debt I want to retire
what do I do the best thing to do is get
a time machine and make better decisions
in the past and that's we're here with
past Tristan trying to help her make
future decisions that that will set her
up to build wealth with less anxiousness
this is literally Breaking Free from
broke there thank you for that book plug
John I'm just saying like this is what
this is this is somebody making 200
Grand who's going to wind up broke this
is how you break free from it there's
just no excuse and we've seen the stats
people making six figures one out of
three paycheck to paycheck with a six
figureure income there is no excuse in
America today to be broke making that
kind of money we've got a break free
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blind drapes and
shutters to motorized Shades they make
it easy and affordable to upgrade your
entire home and their team is ready to
help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
[Applause]
apply
[Music]
this is the ramsy show I'm George
Campell joined by Dr John deloney well
hey you know what time of year it is
it's the annual listener survey
George I knew it wasn't on anyone's
bingo card for me to say annual listener
survey for the Ramsey Show so here it is
guys we want to know your favorite parts
of the show what you like what you don't
like what you want to hear more of more
about whatever it is we want to hear
from you and there are two ways to
participate you can text the word survey
to 3 3789 or you can go to ramsy
solutions.com slss survey and if you're
listening on podcast or YouTube we've
got a link in the show notes to save you
any extra typing that's the last thing I
want for you so either way make sure to
go do that because comments are helpful
and reviews and stuff but the survey is
really where our team digs into this
data and we start to make actual changes
for for the next year based on that so
sign up today and uh you'll here's a
bonus you'll be entered to win a $500
gift card for your time it will take you
a few minutes our research team they
they like to ask questions and we are
not short for those but it is worth your
time and it's so helpful to us so
appreciate you doing that especially if
you say that John is your favorite part
of the show you can do that but that
would also be a bold face
lie so be truthful but also be kind if
like this is not the place just to like
vent and leave a you know 88 page
scathing review of John's performance on
the show that's what George's Twitter
account is for save that it's my private
Twitter account no one has access so go
take the Ramsey Show annual listener
survey text the word survey to 3378 n or
go to Ramsey solutions.com
survey all right let's get to the phones
the number to call Isle 8825 5225
Victoria's up next in Phoenix what's
going on
Victoria hi guys good morning thank you
for taking my call sure how can we help
um we bought a car last year when the
market was really bad for cars um with a
purpose of we plan on visiting all 50
states with our boys and now it's like
okay that the road trip plan sounds like
fun but we are upside down on our car
it's we owe 42,000 and if I Kelly blue
look it right now it's only worth
privately like 30 to
32,000 sorry to hear that what's your
household income
it's last year we ended the year with a
100,000 um but we have to pay last year
we pay taxes about 13,000 this year
we're going to be making more my my
fiance is going to be making more than
100,000 but we're guessing for taxes
we're going to have to we've we have
right now aside 10,000 aside from our
10,000 savings but we're guessing it's
going to be somewhere around 15 16 okay
is he self-employed or contract work
yeah he's self-employed um so we see our
full check every week um it varies
between 2300 to 2900 but again we have
to put aside for taxes okay what other
debt do you
have um just the car in the our house
our house is at
135 okay we're in a 15E house why why
why are you calling about the card are
youall trying to get rid of it are you
just frustrated by it I just don't know
if like it's I'm just trying to see like
is it a good idea that we have this car
for this purpose or no I think it was a
terrible purchas but you've already made
it so it's like if you if you bought a
house and you're in it now we're not
always going to tell you go sell the
house go sell the house and so that
that's the case with this car it's a lot
of your world and a lot of your income
but it's not violating the principles
outside of you going into debt for it so
it's kind of like if you bought a a a
share you know of a stock of a company
and you bought it at the at the at the
height and now the stock took a
well you didn't actually lose money
until you sell that stock so the same
thing is true with this car you can just
ride this out drive this thing to the
wheels fall off pay it off as fast as
possible and go that was a stupid
mistake we're not going to do that
again okay that's what we were aiming
towards I just wanted to get like a
professional opinion like okay what
should we do I didn't I had listened to
their videos on YouTube and some of the
videos were like hey use that saving um
you know pay the difference of whatever
yeah you could do that do you guys have
$10,000
um we have the 10,000 savings but that's
just like our like emergency fund I
really wouldn't want to you know be left
with zero and then if something happens
since my fiance is the only one that
works to be stuck in in a really tight
spot well we teach here is the baby
steps and so baby step two is pay off
all Consumer Debt using the debt
snowball then baby step three is to get
that emergency fund in place so you're
already out of order here so if you
wanted to take that $10,000 and get out
of this car you need a little bit more
money than that to get a different car
of course um but at this point you may
be better off just paying that thing off
as fast as possible making six figures
how quickly could you pay off
42k um if we I think if we stuck to it I
think we could do it in like in a year
that's what I'm talking about and you'll
have what I would call a knucklehead tax
and that is the gap between what you're
upside down because you bought a car at
the height of the market because you
thought you would joy ride America and
it didn't work out so you have to be
like that was dumb like that cost us 12
Grand in depreciation but all right we
won't do that ever ever ever again but
that also means sacrifices like maybe
we're not traveling the country this
year because that's going to cost a lot
of money we may have to hang on to that
dream okay could I add another question
to this
sure um so he's been working at um so
he's self-employed and he's a barber and
roughly every hour he makes like $60 an
hour and his um manager he's been
working with for about 6 years now they
want to open up another shop and he
wants to open up another shop and wants
to have my fiance as half owner okay um
so obviously now he would keep a higher
percentage and he'd be making more per
hour he'd keep all his all his cuts um
but should we pay off this car first or
save up the 50,000 first that we would
need to put in to make this barber shop
to get it going you are broke
okay you're not in a position to buy
into a business right now okay does that
make sense like I it sounds like an
awesome deal probably great your husband
probably crushes if he's making 60 bucks
an hour that's that's George camel
haircut kind of money I don't spend that
much I'm gez that's amazing but like he
must be really good at what he does and
I I bet any person who wants to open a
shop wants to open a shop with a guy
who's that good and who works that hard
and Y are
broke okay fair so the car first nope
fair enough so here's the thing you've
got to make a a decision now is this
dream about starting this business more
important than having a nice car CU if
that's the case you could drive a beater
use your 10K cover the difference on the
loan sell this thing drive a beater car
then save up an emergency fund then save
up 50k on top of that to get this
business going that's a sacrifice but we
can't eat our have our cake and eat it
too we're going to have to do things one
at a time with focused intensity cuz
trying to do everything at once is only
going to slow you guys down in the long
run
yeah that's what it feels like right now
but I want this but hey have him tell
that guy I can do this deal 18 months
from now I'm going to be in a really
good spot to do this deal but until then
I can't do
it okay I think that's enough time the
plaza that they want to open in it's not
even said to be running until fall of
2025 so I here's what here's what George
and I want you and your husband to do I
want youall to sit down and stop talking
so much and I want you to get out a pen
or an Excel sheet and I want want you to
put this plan to paper here's how much
money we make honey you're going to have
to cut hair for a year on Sundays too
you're going to have to work late you're
going have to do till 10 o'clock at
night cuts and honey I'm going to
actually get a part-time job also for
just 12 months and I know we had this
dream that we were going to like so I
was always going to be with the kids but
for this particular season we're going
to work like maniacs to get out of this
thing but I want youall to look at real
numbers on a real piece of paper and
y'all get a plan and y'all swear by it
and then you'll go get married and y'all
do this thing together
Fair super Fair okay very cool okay
sounds like a plan thank you guys
awesome hey this is one of those this is
one of the unforeseen things we talk
about all the time when we talk about
choosing Freedom talk about having
margin it's rare I'm not going to lie
it's
rare but if you are really good at what
you do and you work really hard this
this crazy thing called opportunity
shows up sometimes you plan for it
sometimes it drops out of the Moon and
imagine they hadon about this car cuz
let's go take the boys on every
state what if they just had a beater car
and then the guy comes to them and says
hey $50,000 Buy in you're going to be a
co-owner of this place you're amazing at
what you do and we're about to make you
really
wealthy and now they can't do it because
of they of past decisions cuz they chain
themselves to a depreciating asset
owe anybody money margin and freedom
margin freedom and options baby that's
what this plan's all about you got to do
what it takes though never know when
that Call's coming this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ramsey
personality George camel joined by my
good friend and colleague Dr John
deloney hey if you're a new listener to
the show and you want to dive deeper
into the lingo into the Ramsey Babys
steps that we talk about you can go to
ramsy solutions.com and click on the get
started button and we'll help you figure
out the next best step for your
situation for your financial Journey
based on where you're at today that's
ramsy solutions.com
getstarted hey big news uh mint is
shutting down yes I saw this news this
is wild the uh Financial app the one of
the competitors to every dollar if you
will is shutting down which is 4 million
people suddenly finding themselves
without a budgeting app and lucky for
them we have the greatest budgeting app
on planet Earth every dollar ready for
you so here's what that means for all of
you who feel financially homeless
because you were using mint and now it's
shut down and you're like what do I do
the good news is uh there's an even
better place you can go cuz truthfully
mint wasn't a great financial app for
budgeting all it did it shows you what
happened every dollar shows you how to
plan for what's coming up which is how
you actually break free from broke and
fine margin so if you want to start
budgeting for free you can download
every dollar in your app store and go to
Every dollar.com and uh get started and
we have a great onboarding process that
makes it super easy and in fact John I'm
doing a webinar for every dollar next
Friday uh that is November the 10th
around lunchtime walking people through
how to set up your first every dollar
budget how to use it to find margin
because that's the exciting part we
don't budget just cuz we want to nerd
out we do it so that we can hit
financial goals and so that's a huge
part of it and we're going to show you
exactly how to do that in this webinar
next Friday so you can go to
everydollar.com bugeting to sign up for
that free webinar I encourage you we get
thousands and thousands of people sign
up for those and the feedback has been
awesome because rarely do we get an hour
to really walk through the visuals of
here's what to do answering your
questions and giving you some hope for
your money it's it's it's you you coach
people and hey I want to say this the
sign of a truly mature person a truly
grownup person is being able to
say I don't know how I need some help I
need some coaching help I have had uh
mental health conversations with people
in my family and myself where I've had
to go I had all those classes and I need
to get some different perspective if
you're sitting there
wondering can I say the words out loud I
don't really know how to budget or I get
the idea of budgeting is so stupid and
so easy and yet I never have been able
to figure it out
be a grownup be an adult be somebody who
is humble and says for the sake of my
family and the sake of my me I'm going
to put my pride down and I'm going to
show up to one of these webinars and
learn how to budget you can log in as
Anonymous log in let George be your
coach and do this and for those of you
who are sick and tired of texting your
spouse back and forth that you spent
$314 at whatever I thought you were get
the every dollar app
and if you got friends who are on me who
are like oh my gosh send it to them send
this stuff to them those are your
friends and they don't they may not even
consume the show they may not listened
anything they may not know anything
about every dollar send it to them three
is it three months for free two months
for free yeah you can start a free trial
as well yeah do it do it do it do it do
it this is one of those moments man when
you can help millions of people just by
hitting forward text right easy and
here's the best news unlike mint we
don't sell your data and shove credit
cards and Loans down your throat which
is by the way their entire business
model how do you think mint is making
money and so uh I'm happy I'm actually
elated that mint is shutting down for a
lot of reasons but one is that it wasn't
actually helping people uh it was just
real slick fintech that you know people
Everyone used it and now guess where
they're pushing people John Credit Karma
a and you get what's coming to you when
you sign up for Credit Karma to track
your stupid credit score that's the name
of the company Credit Karma wish I was
in that marketing meeting to tell them
this maybe is not a great name but hey I
don't run things got a great idea for my
new restaurant y so we are called
diarrhea we welcome all of you uh soon
to be financially homeless folks from
mint over to the warmth of every dollar
we got stew you know on the stove we got
cookies bacon in the oven we're ready
for you John with open arms Mama camels
Baka hey don't tease me with a good time
that's okay you made that weird Kelly
Daniel knows she's had my mom's Baka
it's world class so all right let's go
out to Lane in Dallas Lane is in Dallas
Texas if he's still I'm sorry Lane how
you doing pretty good how are youall
today good are you still are you still
glowing about your
Rangers uh I mean yeah I'm not going to
the parade I'm I'm working trying to get
that extra overtime in hey good for you
as an Astros fan I don't think you need
to go but that's that's that's another
conversation so what's
up so uh me and my wife uh
we've been currently uh trying to work
on building our budget trying to get out
of all of our debt and then we kind of
had this conversation last night when we
were looking at the Excel file and she
I'm I'm sitting here trying to plan out
like to an extent roughly like every
paycheck like this is what we need to
meet this goal and she has real bad
anxiety and like she just doesn't want
to deal with any of that but she wants
me just to be like hey here here's this
amount this is what we can spend on this
and just let her go with
that I have I'm sure it exists out there
and people feel free to put it in the
comments I've never heard a successful
marriage conversation about money that
begins with one person saying hey honey
want to see the Excel spreadsheet
Bing and have the other person be like
oh sweet this is gonna be awesome I've
never seen that
no we were uh just sitting about talking
about like our finances because today
was Payday for us so we were talking
about like like and then we were talking
about like what needs to go where and
then we pulled out the spreadsheet
because we've been trying to go through
y this baby step goals and we just now
recently got the $1,000 in savings so we
were trying to look at the debt andnow
how mucht working towards that so we
have about
82,000 I think roughly okay what kind of
debt is it so I have 42,000 in student
loans that's all me I have 177,000 on my
car we have a
$7,000 personal loan about 3,000 in
medical for our son that was just born
in March
May okay and about and about 14 in
credit card Parts oh how much do you
make
man uh together we bring home about
bring home is 7,000 a month okay well
step one we need to increase our income
and also decrease expenses and The
Compound Effect of that will give you
margin to throw extra on top of your
debt so here's what I want you to do
let's skip the spreadsheet I'm going to
gift you 3 months of every dollar
premium and she can log in on her phone
and you both have this app and this is
this is our sheet music that we're
playing from and what you're going to do
is list out your income for the month
followed by all of your expenses list
out all of your debts separately as
minimum
payments and that's going to show you
how much money you either have left over
to throw at the debt or you might be in
the red and you might need to find some
income or cut some expenses but the good
news is every dollar is just a mirror
it's not the Boogey Man it's just
reality which can feel like the
boogeyman but once she faces that and
now you go all right here's the Gap if
we could find $400 a month we could pay
off our debt this much faster which gets
us to this goal even faster that will
start to get her excited versus a
spreadsheet we got to start painting a
picture of what the future is going to
look like and the budget just becomes
our daily GPS to get there anybody who's
sitting with somebody who um they start
to do a budget and they just get super
anxious that's
me we had money challenges growing up
and so my body put a little GPS pin and
conversations about money because they
were always stressful they were always
loud they were always scary and then as
an adult when my wife and I found
ourselves up to our eyeballs in debt my
body started sounding that alarm it's
been that it's been to that place before
and here we go again so if your wife is
feeling anxious instead of trying to
solve that with a spreadsheet I would
close the computer and hold both of her
hands and say hey your body's trying to
get your attention about something
telling you that you're not safe what
are you scared
about and maybe she's going to say hey
when I was a kid money was really scary
around the house and it just remembers
or maybe she's looking at all this debt
and how much money you do or don't
having this little baby that's brand new
and just saying I don't know how all
this works and that's where the baby
step plan getting a plan often helps
with that anxiety hang on the line lane
we're going to send you three months of
every dollar premium two features
specifically I want you to check out
paycheck planning so that you know
exactly when and if you're going to run
out of money and then Financial road map
where you guys get to start to dream
together and see what the future looks
like if you follow this plan with
gazelle intensity this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help you build wealth do work that they
love and create amazing relationships
I'm George camel joined by Dr John
deloney this is your show America give
us a call at
225 it's been an amazing uh launch week
as we've celebrated the launch of my new
book Breaking Free from broke it's now
available for pre-order for just 20
bucks and we're going to bribe you with
$100 worth of bonuses to make it worth
your while including an enhanced audio
book read by me the ebook access to my
newest talk from our smart conference
event and so much more so please go
check sign t-shirts that you've already
worn I heard that's we're not doing that
one yet John we'll work our way up to
the merch one person one lucky person is
going to get um you're going to tattoo
their name on your arm I think that's
more your audience is what that's what
they're looking for I I think this is
the perfect moment for a crossover I
don't think my target demo is tattooed
guys you know that's cool if they are I
don't know if they're out there I think
I think the fintech community is I think
mine's more like former Apple store
employees that's about my speed that are
like ah the sun the Sun but uh I'm
really imp pumped about this book it's
I've been working on it for a year
straight and the whole point of it is to
help people have more money and less
stress and I do that by first exposing
this toxic money system the way we've
all stumbled into it some of it was our
fault some of it was well-meaning
guidance counselors and teachers and
parents and who knows what else a Tik
Tok video that you took some advice from
and so I just want to just Crush through
all that noise and tell you the truth
about money and hit every objection in
your mind and then show you a path to
break free from that and have more time
and money than ever before so that's it
if you want to check that out if that
sounds interesting to you go to Ramsey
solutions.com store and pre-order today
John is up next in Fort Collins Colorado
John welcome to the show
uh yes um I just I'm looking for some
input on possibly changing jobs um I
have about $20,000 in debt um I like
where I work um we're on big step two um
but and we're making things work as is
but it's tight financially I have an
opportunity to make a jump to where I
get a sign on bonus
um of like
$5,000 um and then on top of that I'm be
making about um five um five to6 more an
hour um plus more overtime but I would
be gone more my wife stays at home she
homeschools and takes care of the kids
so this would be
a um stress on her doing at home with
the kids more um my my guess what I
would want to do is when I I leave this
job Cash Out by 401k and pay off all the
debt and that would give us breathing
room no on the other side of that no
don't do any of those things you're
talking about severing your leg off may
make you way less but it's not the
solution to the problem how much how
much do you make in your job right now
um anywhere from 5500 um to 6,500 a
month that's what I take home and you
owe 20,000 bucks and Y are free and
clear yeah 20,000 willo and what's this
new job going to going to net you what
are you going to bring home every week
from it um anywhere from like 65 to 75 a
month so it's it's basically going to be
$1,000 extra a month
yes I will tell you I would much rather
see you keep the job that you love that
allows you to be with your family that
gives you peace and and on on a daily
basis day in and day out and you and
your wife sit down and say for the next
6 months I'm going to get up at 5:00 in
the morning and drive people to the
airport via Uber oryt and I'm going to
drive in the evenings when I get off and
I'm going to earn that extra 12 Grand on
my own and knock this stupid stuff out
okay because you're making a long-term
shift decision you're changing in the
entire Dynamic of your family for 12,000
bucks if you told me it's 20 grand I
would say y'all need to sit down and
have that conversation but just a
thousand bucks a month feels like a
million dollars to you right now because
you can't breathe but I think there's
some things y'all can do right now that
doesn't up in your family so much okay
does that sound right yeah and that's
kind of what I'm looking for um and and
that's probably the advice I need or are
you just exhausted dude just ready for
this to be
done well I
mean yeah I mean I am exhausted but at
the same time this is a job that I do
like um it's close to home but the job
that I would be going to was a job that
I did before um and it did it caused a
lot of stress on my family so yeah um
but it's like the financial stress of
trying to get out of debt if you told me
you were 50 or 100 Grand in debt and
you're going to double your salary that
may be different right I'm I'm all dude
I'm all about like I just got through
with it George and I were just talking
off air writing a book in our jobs and
doing our own shows plus TRS plus being
on the road traveling doing speaking
gigs plus doing internal video shoots
for the business units and Rams like
when you put a book on top of that one
group of people suffers the most and
that's our families because that stuff
is done in the mornings before everybody
wakes up and it's done at nighttime and
it just erodes things and when you're on
the road you're right in hotels so you
get home exhausted it's just chaos and
then you have to go on the road and sell
it and but here's the deal it's a
season and it comes with a reward at the
back end hey it's going to be a Banana's
year and then and we're going to get
hopefully if it sells well we'll get a
little bit of uh income windfall and
then we don't do it again for a couple
of years and so you see what I'm saying
so if you're doing something for a
season I'm dude I'm all in work like a
maniac just go just go guns of Blazing
it's when you say I'm just going to do
this indefinitely and I already have
done this job before I know it's going
to stress me out it's going to stress
the family out for 12 Grand man you can
earn 12 Grand doing other things um
before or after the job you have now
fair I would agree what's your
job uh heavy equipment mechanic I work
for the fire department right now oh
cool so you're you're a handy
guy yeah I I I guess do you know how
much you can make just doing handyman
work in your neighborhood and posting on
Facebook and I'm not talking like
complicated stuff we're talking changing
light bulbs framing up some photos that
kind of stuff how much do you think you
could make an hour I have never looked
didn't do it I'm going to tell you right
now cuz I pay these people and it hurts
my brain that I paid them this much $50
to $90 an hour is what people charge for
handyman work in my
neighborhood you me to blow your mind
even
more my friend Gustavo Menendez came to
the United States he married a
missionary and he was an engineer but
the US wouldn't recognize his
engineering degree because it was from
another country so he had to make money
and he had a truck and a couple hundred
bucks and he now has an unfathomably
successful Mobile Oil Change business
where he comes to your office he comes
to your house and changes the oil in
your car in your
driveway you know what I would pay for
someone to come to my house out in the
woods and do that because it cost me a
whole half day of my life to do that I
got to drive an hour to the place I got
to wait and it says 10 minutes and it
ends up being an hour and a half and I
got to drive an hour
back it's unbelievable and you with your
mechanic skills could fill up Saturdays
and Sunday days and night times and
mornings with oil changes in people's
driveways and you would have your debt
paid off in no time it's about
seasonality and then I want you to start
to ask yourself what am I going to do in
5 years in 10 years are you going to own
your own mechanic shop is there a path
forward I think that's the question you
need to be asking do I love this work
and what comes after this but man I
wouldn't quit your job right now not for
12 Grand I'd find that money scratch and
Claw get
it
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level net week gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at nets.com Ramsey that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsay show I told
you uh what time of year it was it's the
annual listener survey time of year but
it's also Christmas Cash giveaway time
that's here too you could win one of our
$500 weekly prizes or the grand prize of
$5,000 that's just our way of uh you
know giving away Dave's money it's the
most fun you can have with money is
giving away your money followed by
Dave's money so enter every day to
increase your chances of winning at
Ramsey solutions.com
giveaway you can also get some
meaningful gifts for Christmas during
our $12 sale uh we've got bestselling
books on there for 12 bucks like The
Total Money Makeover baby steps
Millionaires and own your past change
your future for just 12 $ each and John
this is exciting questions for humans
conversations cards are as low as 10
bucks right now plus the popular
questions for humans Christmas edition
is back those sold out last year so get
them while you can hey and we got a new
one uh we got two new ones this year
Thanksgiving we're going to save your
Thanksgiving if you are already dreading
Thanksgiving just sitting around the
table staring at that one family member
who will not shut up about politics and
has an opinion on every there's every
family has that one person that's still
talking about Co just can't let it go
let stop I got you questions for humans
Thanksgiving and then we have a new one
and this was people were just asking and
asking and asking for it so we sat down
with
experts kids and grandparents and we
have a grandparents and kids deck so if
you take your kids to uh Thanksgiving or
Christmas you can go on a date and your
their grandparents aren't just going to
hand them digital babysitters they can
actually sit and talk and communicate
learn all about your parents I'll be
home for Thanksgiving so I'm going to
give it to my parents and say can you
ask my two-month old these questions
exactly get her talking it'll be perfect
I want hold hold on we're GNA I'm going
to do a question with you okay um what
are one or two things you'd like to be
thankful for next year that I'd like to
be this is aspirational gratefulness
aspirational gratitude that's right uh I
think uh my health think is taken for
granted and with some recent family
stuff I'm like wow like this is all we
have and it goes quick we got one body
yep one Health so you know I want to
make the most of that I want to be more
grateful for it and uh with action of
steps exell like moving my body like
John says to do here's another one when
did you last write a handwritten letter
who is it to and what was it
for I'm going to say my wife's birthday
when was
that last year gosh I'm the worst well
probably to a team member here I do some
thank you cards to the team that doesn't
count how about you you do it every day
I'm sure I do a lot so listen here's I
think would be really cool what if you
she she doesn't listen to the show let's
be honest no what if you wrote Whitney a
handwritten letter just telling her what
an amazing job she's doing as a brand
new mom
ooh that would get tears flowing in the
best way mean you don't want to just
make your wife cry there's other ways
you do that too I've seen it but I think
just like saying hey I I just want you
to know I
see how amazing you are because I say it
a lot but there's something about having
it written on paper that hits different
she can go back to it and go back to it
and go back to it and go back to it yeah
that's good all right last one
what's the most binge worthy TV show
right now oh man I'm going to do one
that's not going to embarrass me how
about that fair um it's Gilmore Girls
you love Gilmore Girls well I did just
watch the Beckham documentary which for
those of you who think I don't know
about sports I still don't but I also
watch the Beckham documentary I know
there was a soccer player next to one of
your favorite pop stars of all time
watch for po spice uh I'm going to say
the bear on Hulu I keep hearing about
this a great show can I tell you what I
stumbled into that I'm exactly 10 years
ler on homeland oh that feels very
delony that you think you're an extra on
homeland I I I dream of one day just
getting a knock on my door in the woods
and the CIA is like we need you and I'm
like I'm in gosh what a weird dream the
YouTube YouTubers came and like look at
us connecting John thanks to these
cards I wasn't even tempted to pull out
my phone and ignore this conversation
because they were so good so questions
for humans Ramy solutions.com say your
holidays y so reminder the giveaway is
happening at ramsy solutions.com
giveaway and then check out the $12 sale
at ramsy solutions.com store and while
you're there you'll see my book there
it's not 12 bucks cuz it's brand new
eventually we'll make it to the $12 sale
but it's worth adding to cart and maybe
you'll hit free shipping if you get to
you know 50 bucks so there you go all
right let's get to Valerie in Atlanta
Georgia Valerie what's going
on hi thank you both so much for taking
my call I greatly appreciate being here
sure um sometimes I try to use humor to
get through things so if I say something
and y'all are laughing at it but I'm
serious at the same time I am new I'm
kind of ramsy is trying to be much more
involved um I was on the um Ken Coleman
show not once but twice um he didn't
tell me I was a hot mess but I've heard
Dave Ramsey say basically some of the
things that I'm experiencing I'm a hot
mess I have the mind of a gazelle but
I'm waddling around like a penguin I
can't get I can't get anywhere I'm
that's self aware at least Valerie I
appreciate that
Honesty so how can we help if Ken
Coleman couldn't help you who
can what's going on I'm sorry oh you're
good you're good so you're 58 and you
sound like you're scared to death and
and he's thinking yeah John you can you
can help me that's why he hooked me up
with you he said I really probably
needed needed to talk to you um I wanted
to come to the book signing we don't
have any money so basically I'm married
to somebody much I'm trying to talk fast
and if I talk too fast let me know but
I'm trying to get it all in because it's
a big mess okay a huge huge big mess go
for it had an accident four years ago um
Ken tried to get you know Ken coached me
along a little bit about trying to get a
better paying job I was making six
figures I'm not even making but $16
working a big box retail now and it's
extremely stressful and the hours are
from 11: to 8: so I can't really get a
serving job you know at night or do
other things but anyway long story short
I've been doing a lot of trying to get a
new job I've uh been in counseling twice
a week because I'm I had to learn to
walk again I had to learn to get out of
bed by myself my husband was by my side
um this happened in another country in
the Netherlands but when I came home I
couldn't do anything and he was still
stuck in the Netherlands I was back here
in the States and couldn't do anything
um by myself I had to go to therapy and
everything this happened about four
years ago so I'm a financial wreck 58 no
savings don't even have I can't even pay
my bills my my money doesn't even cover
my bills but I'm so
anxious and sometimes honestly I do
still life term life insurance policy
because Dave says have term rather than
whole I do have that and I feel like I'm
worth more dead than alive I mean I
can't I can't get out of this mess I I
just don't know where's
husband husband is 75 can't work um here
in the states legally and he's retired
so he is somewhat on the same page with
you know he does help a little bit every
month very little because he still got a
place it's a long story but I mean he
does not even have a green card in our
country because that's $5,000 we don't
have okay um so you're the
your income for the house making 16 an
hour how much debt do you guys
have we have as as a couple I mean it's
me uh this is all prior to us being
married 47,000 um go over that that's
why I'm in such a horrific horrific
shape and Ken told me to talk to you
guys because not only am I anxious every
day and nervous and just a financial
wreck um 20 of that is two Parent Plus
Loans
um I'm 145 upside down in my truck have
tried to work out a settlement don't
know I mean like I can't even buy a
hoopie there's no way to even go out and
buy one of those to get you know to do
the side hustles I'm not an excuse maker
no you're stuck hold on hold on hold on
yeah I'm stuck couple things you're
stuck and you ain't gonna hear that from
George and I that we're going to clown
on you you're in an absolute mess and I
want you to make complete and total
peace with your body if the anxiety
alarms weren't ringing off the hook
inside your body I would tell you you
need to go to a physician
immediately your anxiety right now means
your body is working about
perfectly it's perfect okay so hang on
the line we're going to roll this call
over we're going to go to break and then
we come back we're going to walk you
through some potential challenges and
some potential opportunities this is a
mess and this is very very hard okay
stay with us we'll be right back right
here on the Ramy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank y refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qu qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey show we were
on the line with our friend Valerie in
Atlanta let me recap her situation for
you she's 58 her husband's 75 he can't
work in this country and they can't
afford the Green Card they're $47,000 in
debt between a parent Plus loans and
being upside down on a truck and she's
making $16 an hour working retail and
feels stuck along with a a an accident
that has left her kind of picking up the
pieces so Valerie are you still with us
here yes sir I am did I sum it up
accurately pretty much yes sir okay yes
so hey I want to jump in here
and I know that you have been
repeatedly hit upside the head over the
last four or five or six years
right yes and when that happens to us
often we develop some pretty amazing um
defense mechanisms and so I want you to
do me a favor and I want you to tighten
your hands really tight right now can
you do that can you squeeze both your
hands as tight as you
can and then I want you to relax them
and open them up completely okay drop
your shoulders I'm going to Rattle a
bunch of stuff off for the sake of time
and then I'm going to hook you up with a
couple things at the end of this okay
but I want you to think through some of
these things all right thing number one
I want you to write a letter to your
former self that used to make six
figures that woman is haunting you right
now cuz you used to be incredible
right yes yeah and I think you still are
you're hanging in there you're a boxer
that's on the Rope but you're ropes but
you're still hanging in there and all
you can remember is when you used to be
champ and you can't see that actually
the fighting that's going on right now
you're actually stronger and tougher
than you used to be okay I want you to
write her a letter and say you miss
her and but she's gone now and so what
we're going to do is we're going to deal
in the reality that we have here we're
going to shift that identity to who we
used to be to who we are and we are
Scrappy and tough now number two I want
you to have a hard conversation with
your kids and let them know I signed
these Parent PLUS alone
I can't pay my bills to
eat and I want you to tell them this is
embarrassing this is hard this is scary
whatever words you want to
use but that you need them to help with
the cost of their college education at
least for the foreseeable
future and they might tell you forget
you Mom we're not doing that whatever
you're right I signed my name on it and
if you want to watch your mom drowned
then you can watch
that but I need some
help the third thing is
I drove by this morning my daughter and
I went to breakfast and I drove by a
McDonald's and on the sign it said 20
bucks an
hour I want you to take all of the
imaginary Pride you have and I want you
to you are locked into eight at 8:00 to
11:00 p.m. job or whatever time you work
right now I want you to be very honest
about your local
area and it might be working at fast
food it might be working two fast food
jobs McDonald's in the morning Taco
Bells in the evening or Arby's in the
morning and whatever I don't care cuz
right now we got to get that income
up
okay it's going to be a swallowing of
Pride that you is going to be I I I just
hurt for you and you're going to come
out on the back end of this so strong
the next thing I want you to do is I
want you to call Social Security office
and see what the status is have you
already done
that what do you mean if you you have a
disability that prohibits you from doing
the work that you used to be able to do
you may be eligible for Social Security
early well I I I can actually I I was
going to tell you four years later I am
walking now I'm getting out of bed by
myself and I'm fine mentally I'm a mess
okay but physically I can I'm being real
I can actually work now I've been
applying that's why Ken said get some
help with your mental state you know and
ask John for some advice on being so
anxious and why do you think hold on why
do you think you're a
mess
um I'm a mess because well I feel like
I'm a failure I you're asking me the
total picture feel like I'm a failure
okay not true hold on not true go to the
next thing what's the next thing um I
feel like I'm not good enough okay not
true go to the next
thing my kid
uh I I feel like I'm a failure to my my
grown kids my kids are grown that's
false that's not true what you've just
told me is a lot of
feelings and you're being run by your
feelings not by
data and so it's an old cognitive
behavioral technique that any counselor
should have had you do which is to write
down these feelings that are burying you
and then I want you to demand evidence
from them is that true I feel like a
failure to my grown
kids is that
true did I raise them feel how they see
me hey they're grown-ups they can see
you however you want they may not be
true either
right I want you to take these thoughts
and I want you to write them down all
these feelings and challenge them take
them head on and if you can't see the
forest from the trees call your kid hey
I've been really wrestling with this
idea that I'm a failure is that
true no Mom we freaking love you you we
miss
you and I want you to take those on I
don't think your body's screwed up I
don't think you're a mess if I had a
75-year-old person spouse if my wife was
75 and I loved her and she couldn't work
and she was drowning in her own shame
and she was getting older and I was
terrified and I had this wreck and I
used to be a six-figure earner and now
I'm making 16 bucks an hour I'd be
anxious too every person on the planet
would be anxious that's why I don't know
that the anxiety is the thing to go
solve right now I think the thing to
solve
is fighting going to war against these
negative bull craap feelings because
they're not true you're not a failure
you're still
standing you're are absolutely
incredible you have fought back from not
being able to get out of bed and now
you're
working now I want you to see that worth
more than 16 bucks an hour cuz you're
worth more than
that I want you to hang on the line
because this isn't just a oneandone
thing okay we're going to do a couple
things number one I'm going to hook you
up with three nope six I'm going to hook
you up with six months of free
counseling with my friends at better
help you can do that from home so you
don't have to drive anywhere okay it's
it's online the second thing is we're
going to hook you up with three sessions
with a financial coach with Ramsey
Financial coaches for free okay they're
going to walk through your budget
specifically
and they're going to help pull you apart
and show you that it is that bad and
here's some ideas or it's actually not
that bad or actually maybe it's in the
middle you're going to get some data
some facts Okay the third thing is I'm
going to send you three months free of
every dollar the app that you can track
your money and you can begin to get some
little wins little bits of control over
this thing slowly and
surely anxiety comes when we project the
future is going to be a certain way and
it scares us and we start trying to
solve it in the present and it's an
imaginary
future you have to head into that
anxiety I'm terrified about what comes
next cool I'm going to go figure out
what comes next I'm terrified I'm not
going to have enough money cool I'm
going to go get a second job and a third
job because now I can get up I'm
terrified about count about my feelings
cool I'm going to see a counselor and
I'm going to use CBT techniques I'm
going straight after these feelings that
aren't true we're going right into the
storm and we're going to hook you up
with people to walk with you thank you
for being brave thank you for the call
you are awesome awesome awesome good
stuff John thank you for that one last
thing Valerie the first thing you buy is
food the next thing you need to buy is
shelter the next thing is utilities
we're paying for light paying for the
water bill and the next thing is
clothing basic necessities that's it
that means the car loan folks they can
kick rocks and pound sand cuz you don't
have the money to pay the student loan
companies they can also kick rocks and
pound sand because you don't have the
money to pay you come first the
creditors they can wait and I love
John's advice about getting the kids to
pitch in even though it's legally on you
I think the kids need to step up and
help Mom in her time of need and we can
get you out outside of this upside down
truck situation you need to go over
there and say listen you got a bad loan
on your hands I need the difference to
get out of this mess and you're going to
have to fight that to get out of that
mess and get you something you can drive
to work but we're rooting for you
America is rooting for you and John
hooked you up with so many resources
that I hope helps you take the right
Next Step this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramy show today's
question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
when you want to repair maintain or
improve your home stop wasting time
scrolling through pages and pages of
providers and Googling around neighborly
is all you need to remember for a
nationwide network of local Home Service
professionals visit neighborly
docomo find Reliable help near you all
right today's question comes from Monica
in New Hampshire she writes I have a
question about the debt snowball I feel
like I've been doing it all wrong my two
debts are my car loan and student loans
my car loan is
$8500 um my student loans total are
whopping $1
$20,000 but this is split over 16
different loans 12 of the loans are
lower than the car loan my loans are in
deferment since I'm in school but
interest has started Should I stick with
tackling the car loan or turn my gazelle
intensity to the smaller student loans
thank you for your help ooh this is like
a common core math
riddle Jane except there will be an
actual answer to this one yes we can
actually solve this this puzzle here
okay so loans are in deferment you're in
school interest has started Should I
stick with tackling the car loan I
assume she's working while in school
which I like that there's income coming
in at the same time uh or turn the
gazelle intensity to the smaller student
loans I'm going to this is what I did
personally so I'll tell you what I did I
had you know 12 13 different little
loans and it was so much more freeing to
see them as little ankle biters and list
them out smallest to largest than it was
to see
$120,000 student loans so baby steps I
would do it you can do it in a
spreadsheet but what's really helpful
now I didn't have every dollar back then
but with every dollar when you list out
your budget you can list all of your
debts smallest to largest it does it for
you and you'll list out your minimum
payments your loan balances and that
will show you what to tackle next and
how much margin you have in your budget
to throw at that smallest debt so
absolutely let's tackle the smallest one
first let's knock out that little one
you have 11 more student loans to go
then the car loans will sit in the mix
then you'll have those last four student
loans and you're going to free up so
many payments along the way that you get
this thing called hope and momentum and
motivation and that's what keeps you
going and it's why I love the debt
snowball yeah there's something powerful
you can spend 9 months knocking that car
loan down to $3,000 or you can spend 9
months and you have 16 loans and now you
only have six and there's just something
psychological about that we we say that
all the time it's it's it's 80% Behavior
20% math right and so the the psychology
the behavior part these tiny little wins
over and over and over again so I love
that advice George well and 12 student
loans are lower than that $88,500 car
loan so that tells you're going to knock
these out so fast and you're actually
going to get there faster and the math
people like to argue about the Deb
Avalanche and paying the highest
interest first stupid the math is
negligible uh but isn't is the
psychology that will get you to the
actual Finish Line and so love it way to
go call us up when you're debt free
Monica we'll celebrate with you all
right Logan is in Atlanta up next Logan
what's going
on you with
us yes sir what's going on hey uh so I
have a question question uh I'm 20 years
old and I do travel construction work
and my company has a 401k type plan not
exactly a
401k um I'm not sure what they called it
but they decided to cancel it and
actually handed me everything that I
contributed this morning and I was
wondering uh what I should do with that
money I'm on step two I recently just
started the plan I friend recommended it
to me um I I I got the $1,000 last week
and now I'm uh I'm yeah so I'm looking
to see what to do with that money
awesome how much is
it uh so it's a it was a 20 every $20
you put in they only put in 10 so uh
until I got my debts paid I was only
putting in about 40 bucks a week so it's
uh only
$800 okay and what's your debt on did
they keep their match did they just keep
their money so it was a it's like this
deal where until 15 years you're not
100% invested and I was only year so
years yeah and you're still with this
company yeah you work for the
mob uh well I'm only about a year in
with this company I'm I'm 20 years old
yeah dude you're young enough that you
don't realize that they are taking so
much advantage of you you're working for
unethical people I've never heard of it
taking 15 years to
vest yeah the percentage it goes up
every every year or something like that
but so they held your money held your
money for a year they made interest on
your money they matched your money and
then they're like eh we're not doing
this anymore here's your money back
we'll keep the interest we earned off
your 800 bucks and we're going to keep
the money that we're going to match 15
years from
now yeah I guess so yeah it's called
sketchy so I was wondering what to do
with that and um I'm going to get into a
Roth when I get my debts paid off um but
so yeah I was just wondering what to do
with that money should I save it throw
it at the debt you're in baby step two
you already have $1,000 so any money
above that let's start throwing at the
debt so what's your next smallest
debt okay so yeah I have a I have a car
loan and then I have two I have a ATV
loan and I have personal loan for a
truck that I owned previously I fixed so
I could sell it because it was giving me
a lot of problems and it was just cost
me money to own you have an addiction to
wheels and Motors don't you my man well
yeah your ATV I was under the impression
that it was going to build up my credit
so I purchased that when I was 18 and I
found out that that was not the case so
what
dude oh your ATV is sold this weekend
okay it's going Logan I'm so glad you're
20 because you have so much time to
never make dumb mistakes again and that
gives me great joy that you're only like
two years into adulthood and you can
undo a lot of this and still have the
next 40 years to build wealth and not
remain
broke yes sir so what is the next
smallest debt on the
list so it's I have a $1,700 debt um
from a truck repair that one's the first
and then the ATV is second and I owe
about s on it what's it worth what could
you sell it
for I think it's probably only worth
about four so I was planning on trying
to pay it get the difference and then
try to sell it as fast as I can okay and
the personal loan
uh well the personal loan was for the
truck fix that's the smallest one at
$1,700 and then the car loan and I have
a car loan at 17,000 what's this car
worth um probably about 12 to 13
goodness and what do you
make uh I make about $50,000 a year
okay oh so we're underwater in pretty
much everything in our life and I want
to get you above water and that means
sacrifices no more toys it means working
double can you work overtime can you
pick up three more
jobs uh well I work out of town so
that's that's not actually possible for
me can you go get a different job doing
the same thing
locally um I'm not sure I I get pretty
decent hours working out of town and um
a a family member is is in this business
and he's very high up and he's kind of
guiding me to get to where he is um so
that's kind of the main reason I'm
working for the company Logan your
company sucks
I don't like this point and if I was
doing a Consulting gig and I was sitting
with your president of your company
behind closed doors I would tell him the
same thing he's taking advantage of 20
year
olds yes sir could you make $25 an hour
locally doing
construction uh I'm not sure it's not
really something I've looked into I make
about 22 right now I just got a raise so
listen homie this morning I just
mentioned this on another call this
morning I was taking my daughter to
breakfast and I drove past a sign at a
MC Donald's that was starting at $20 an
hour and this is in rural
Tennessee and if you worked at
McDonald's in rural Tennessee you'd make
almost the same money except you'd get
to sleep in your own bed and you
wouldn't have to travel and you could
have friends and community and possibly
work a small weekend job to make a
little bit more money and probably have
better benefits than what you have now I
promise you would have better
benefits you have this picture dude dud
I'm just I'm just telling you if you
were my brother or my son or a close
friend of mine I would tell you I don't
work for people I don't trust period I
just don't man Life's too short and if
they're going to do this to you they're
going to take advantage of you and then
Pat you on the back and then say look
how great we are dude I'm I am out I'm
out man I'm going to start doing some
homework Logan to see what jobs are
available in my area talk to people who
are doing those jobs how much do they
make do they enjoy it and I'm going to
try to work locally so that you can bust
your butt work overtime and not be on
the road and stuck in this cycle man get
a girlfriend hang out enjoy your life
smile chips and c and salsa dude that's
what it's all about that puts this hour
of the ramsy show in the books we'll be
back before you know
[Music]
it
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George Campell joined by my good friend
Dr John deloney and we're taking your
calls at
88255 225 it's been a fun week for me
John as we've been uh pre- launching my
new book Breaking Free from broke after
34 years on Earth 10 years at Ramsay and
one year of writing it just feels good
to be done with something you know wo
well you did you did have a child that
was kind of cool that's true I actually
sent the final book in while I was in
the delivery room when he was like Hey
over here man I was like yeah yeah one
second hang hang one second luckily we
made it just in time but I'm pumped for
this book it's called Breaking Free from
broke the Ultimate Guide to more money
and less stress and I of course I start
with my story of I went from broke to
millionaire in a decade following this
proven Ramsay plan no Tik Tock hacks no
shortcuts just good oldfashioned debt
snowball emergency funds investing in
the 401K getting a house the right way
the ramsy way paying it off early in our
early 30s and then showing people that
it's possible for them too that sounds
so boring I know but it's so peaceful it
sounds so like you're should have
passive income and more leverage George
you're leaving money
zero leverage have you seen me I'm so
short I don't think I could leverage
anything John that is true the other
side of the Teeter Totter would launch
you into into order I know how fulcrums
work I remember fourth grade when we
studied that uh but I really had one
goal with this book John and it was to
write a book about money that didn't
feel like a root canal that had not just
opinions but research that wasn't just
information but it had humor using data
too I know I had 130 sources I'm like
what I John delone this thing you love a
good source EXA well part of it was I've
heard every objection $1,000 isn't
enough and what's wrong with using my
credit card if I pay it off every month
and you need a credit score to live your
financial life and so I went on top of
all the anecdotal experience from
millions of our audience and fans
there's also research to back up why the
debt snowball Works research to back up
that you spend more when you use a
credit card so I bust the myths about
credit scores car loans credit cards
student loans Auto Loans mortgage traps
investing traps marketing and
consumerism and then show people how to
break free from all that and live a more
peaceful life and build wealth and ditch
debt and buck the system there you go
and deprogram all the crap we learned
growing up learn all the stuff we didn't
learn growing up the right way all that
financial literacy and it's all there in
about uh 300 pages that will breeeze by
and we got an audiobook ebook and you
get all of that free when you pre-order
so it's just 20 bucks to pre-order the
book you get a whole bunch of goodies
with it and uh 100 bucks worth of
bonuses including three months of every
dollar premium so you can go check that
out at Ramsey Solutions
/st and I appreciate all the support
comments messages from all of you so far
letting me know that you pre-ordered it
and you're sending it to your friends
and family means the world let's get to
the phones Dustin is right down the road
in Nashville Tennessee what's going on
Dustin hey George hey John how are you
all great how are
you I'm great I just had a quick
question about manual underwriting let's
do it this is my Super Bowl I've heard
it's not real heard Jade say before um
that you know when you cut up your
credit cards your score takes about a
year to drop to zero so my question is
is my wife and I are on baby step two
we're said to pay off all our debt of
November of 24 awesome um and so uh once
we get to the mortgage process right um
you know we cut our cred not then but
we'll cut up our credit cards and it'll
take about a year so but Jada said you
know if you have a bad score it will it
be a harder time when we got to do the
manual underwriting process if it hasn't
reached all the way to zero yet yeah so
to do a no score loan they won't let you
do it if you have a score and so would
this be both you and your you have a
spouse uh yes my wife okay so both of
you to get on the loan would have to
have no score and so okay what this
process and here's the thing it's not
really a problem it feels like more of a
problem but think about it this way once
you're debt free you still need to save
up 3 to six months of expenses in an
emergency fund you still need to save up
a big down payment so it's probably
going to take a year to do all that
anyways isn't it right yeah for sure
okay so it's it's really a non-issue
following the Ramsey Baby Steps because
it takes time to then go from baby step
2 to 3B where you have the down payment
saved and one other thing to think about
in this process um what's your do you
have a down payment savings
goal um I was kind of I was actually
looking at a calculator today so
probably roughly 20% down than what you
all recommend so it'd probably be like
80 okay and then an emergency fund have
you calculated what that might be yes
for that would be 20,000 okay months so
we have to cash flow another 100 Grand
plus closing costs plus moving expenses
plus Furniture so this home ownership
dream may still be two years
away okay gotcha what's your
income uh so household income after
taxes um is 60,000 okay so one thing I
would do if I'm in your shoes is get the
income up over the next year or two
because that's going to help you get to
this down payment savings goal because
let's say you could save up $1,000 a
month for the down payment that's 12
Grand a year it would take 5 grand to
save up
60 right five years so what I want to
see is hey how do we get $2,000 worth of
margin to get to 24,000 a year now we're
talking that's 50 grand every two years
boom what do you do what do you do for a
Liv in
Dustin uh I work in
it and is your wife work outside the
home yes so she uh she is currently
looking for a different job but she
currently works as a speech language
pathology assistant okay those are both
great careers I want to see you go hey
how do we go I can find a job in it
making 65 and she can go make 55 or 60
now all of a sudden we have six figures
to work with with no debt now we've got
some margin to throw at this down
payment savings
goal right yeah I've been working on
certifications just so I have more
opportunities to uh to grow my income
why don't you work here at Ramsey
Solutions I've looked at it that's an
option you're right here in Nashville
just throwing it out there we got a lot
of it people so there you go but yeah
it's going to take a while DUS so I
wouldn't worry as much about manual
under about that process of will I have
a score or not because it's far enough
away that you won't here's one thing to
do make sure all of your accounts are
closed pull your credit report you can
do it at annual
creditreport.com and pull that for free
to see do I have any accounts open that
I forgot about that weren't fully closed
because that will affect whether or not
you still have a score so thanks for
that oh that's good John this is a
question that this one boggles people's
minds and Jade warshaw and I and you
we've we've done this where you get a
manual underwriting no score loan
because once you get out of debt you
don't have a credit score and we get a
lot of flack for it and again this is
something I cover in the mortgage
chapter of my new book and people go
well it's you're going to have terrible
terms it can't be done no lenders do it
and I go you've never done it people how
are you coming at me I'm telling you I
did it and it wasn't that hard so manual
underwriting just means that it's not
automated through Ai and Technology it
doesn't run through software it's a real
person the underwriter looking at your
J's financial situation going all right
John's there's Jon's tax returns we see
that Jon makes this income here's uh
ontime monthly payments for Jon's rent
and utilities and insurance and child
care all right let's give John the loan
and here's the for those non- Bankers in
the room who say those things here was
here was my moment when I went ah okay
the game is rigged
if Dave Ramsey gave you and I a million
dollars in cash and we put it in the
bank and let it sit for 6 months it
would not impact our credit score one
point so it has nothing to do with how
wealthy you are how much about
management yes that's bad and hey if you
want to get in touch with the folks we
trust to do these no score loans it's
Churchill chill those are the folks to
trust go to ramsy solutions.com and get
in touch with
[Music]
them
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney we're taking your calls at
8825 5225 and friendly reminder for you
we've got the $12 sale happening at the
Ramsey store right now at ramsy
solutions.com store you can get a bunch
of the questions for humans con
conversation cards for as low as 10
bucks Total Money Makeover baby steps
millionaires own your past change your
future for just $12 each so Now's the
Time to start shopping and John we've
got a new deck of questions for humans
Thanksgiving Edition we have
Thanksgiving we're going to save your
holidays we got Christmas got nothing
can save you from congealed salad that
stuff's disgusting actually the question
one of the questions what's been the
most awkward Thanksgiving dish of your
life 100% it was congealed salad and I
was at a very Southern traditional
Thanksgiving and so I I didn't know what
I was looking at John I it if sometimes
not done well is looks like somebody has
already eaten it and then they just put
it in Jell-O it looked like if you took
something through a garbage disposal and
then just put it in a nice little Jello
ramkin and called it good I I can't eat
that but it's on the plate and I have to
be you know polite so I took one bite I
would never have never would have you
ever smashed food around on the plate to
make it look like you ate more than you
did poite no that's me I just atat it
how about you um there's a pink salad
with like uh it's pink and has raisins
and like marshmallows and and like
little bits of pony and I don't know
eyelids I don't know what's in it but
God that's just awkward yeah I'll take
sweet potato casserole now we're talking
now see I like to rub that on my face
all right so is it easier to ask for
help from family or from friends why
friends 100% why uh there's less baggage
attached there's less you know less of a
trauma Bond there cuz with family
there's always like another there's it's
going to un unroll and unravel a whole
another thing ah you know what I mean if
I ask my dad for to help move he's like
well who are you movers and what do you
let me dive into a thousand more details
when a friend just like yeah what time
exactly that's it that's all I just want
that to be that simple I'm with or hey
Dad um what's the uh what's your thought
on XYZ I taught you that back all right
we just yeah yeah so I I love family I
rarely ask them for things just less on
the line with friends there you go I
don't want to I'd rather you know sour
those relationships in family is I guess
what I'm trying to say you get new
friends you're stuck with your family oh
that was fun you can check out that deck
of cards at r solutions.com store and
get them in time for Thanksgiving Joseph
is in Chicago Joseph what's going
on hey guys thanks for taking my call um
I just have a question on my student
loans so I have about 58,000 in student
loans it's had a really low interest
rate
2.6% um and I'm set to pay it off uh by
August 2026 my monthly payments about
19900 I also have a home loan of 380,000
at 6% and I'm just wondering if I should
just bite the bullet and pay off the
rest of my student loans I've already
paid off about a hundred so I have about
100,000 in cash also have 160 and
401K um but I'm just wondering if I
should do that or keep it in the market
earning
57% half of it's in a high interest
savings so I'm earning 5% there um it's
just that low interest rates really I
would pay them off before the day is
over really and here's why I tell you
that that's not just me taking up advice
cuz that's exactly what I
did I cannot tell you dude the the sole
tax on your amydala is worth more than
the
2.1% extra money you're earning in this
little weird snapshot in history in a
high yield savings account over the
interest rate you have on these
loans every time every time a stock
ticker Rolls by that has something about
forgiveness or for this you look up your
heart rate increases your body fills up
with cortisol in Adrenaline cuz that's
that involves
you I literally did not look up other
than to hear from hurting people about
the Biden forgiveness plan because I
paid him
off just didn't I mean just didn't
didn't
care and that's worth any percentage of
money that I could have earned in a high
yield savings account
period yeah I think that's I mean that's
kind of the path I've been leaning
towards it's it's just uh by the end of
the day pay it
off all right I think that's probably
the best advice have you done the math
on what you would actually
earn um it'd be about like an extra
maybe 5,000 a
year well you're making five you said
you have 100,000 in cash and savings
making 5% right
yeah I got 65 in a brokerage account and
then I got 35 you have way too much
money to still be having debt around
your neck it just doesn't make sense
you're too successful and you're too
smart what is your what is your degree
in I have a law degree I'm an attorney
yeah how much do you
make um 300 maybe 330 with
bonus why do you have why do you have
student loans man well I mean it was 165
so I've already paid off 110 like August
2026 sounds like an eternity away like I
don't even know bro hey I'm gonna be
listen I was a DEA students at a law
school for years okay so I I get
it choose to be free for the first time
in your life
man owe nobody
anything and then if you decide to
reduce your billables hours by X or your
partner says hey we're going to need you
to do this before we consider you can go
I'm not doing that because I don't owe
anybody anything here's a fun exercise
Joseph go make an every dollar budget
where there's no debt in the picture and
you make
$380,000 and then tell me that you would
go back in time and go yeah I'll take
the debt at a low interest rate for fun
man if I'm in your shoes I'm going to
use this incredible income and this
incredible you know stock p of cash that
you have and go I'm going to pay off
these student loans I'm going to start
attacking the house and I'm going to be
a baby steps millionaire in no time and
you should be making 380 instead of
hanging on to debt for the next three
four five years because of a low
interest rate hey you know why you know
who makes you go to work tomorrow the
government because you owe them what a
sucker dude pay pay them off today you
have a $100,000 in cash you could be
debt free today right except for your
house
yeah that's right give me the final
number you about 55 left on them is that
right 58 yeah I mean I guess my only
thing is if I have 100,000 earning 5
six% over the next three years I'll earn
15,000 in interest and you know
$380,000 I mean the five grand a year is
not changing your life it's fun money
that's okay do this that's true don't go
to a bar for six months there's your
$5,000 it's also true or get one of
those suits just don't replace it that's
your
$5,000 yeah dude my dissertation was on
the mental health of attorneys I
know I know and here's what I'm telling
you choose Freedom over being right
choose Freedom over
2.1% difference
between um what you owe the government
versus what you're making in a high
yield account right
now choose peace because you go to war
every day that's what you do for for
guys like me I call you and say help and
you go I will I got you and so the
greatest gift you can give yourself when
you are a Hired Hand when you are
somebody who all you do all day is go to
battle for other people the greatest
gift you can give yourself is a good
night's sleep is peace in your house and
when you owe money to the government and
they're telling you no you're going to
get these 2200 billable hours because
you owe us you owe me bro take just take
that off the table I'd be debt free
before the afternoon is over and by the
way you'll still have $40,000 in the
account Cry Me a River with $100 bills
you're good I'm proud of you man
congratulations I've I've seen people
post this they go I have a mortgage at
2.75% I'm going to stay in this house
forever and I go golly you've locked
yourself in a prison over an interest
rate exactly you have changed yourself
so if you want to move you're like no
because then we have to take on a bigger
interest interest rate I can't move I'm
stuck what kind of Life have you built
for yourself when you don't have options
be free choose Freedom just be free
forget rate JZ freedom I know goodness
gracious it's available to you but it
starts with going it's more than math
I'm solving for Freedom here that part
is a partial math equation but it takes
some getting out of your own head and
getting out of your own way and going we
could have all of our income back that's
our greatest wealth building tool why
are we giving it to lenders thinking
that we're winning that's not how it
works this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camell joined by Dr John deloney
we've got some special guests on the
debt free stage it's Greg and Kim how
are you guys just fine just fine nervous
no it's John and I what do you got to be
nervous about you're doing great thank
you and you're debt free yeah that's one
more reason to be peaceful that's it
okay tell us about it where are you guys
from shreport Louisiana wonderful thanks
for I 20 I20 I2 this man knows his
interstates I know here's what I know I
know where the cooking is good in the
United States in treport yes they know
how to eat I love it okay so tell us how
much debt did you guys pay off
124,125
woo and how long did that take three
years three years okay and what was the
range of income during that time between
70 to 108 awesome what do you guys do
for a living I'm in retail and I work
for the local jail cool and I'm a
director of uh member services at my
church and a local nonprofit
organization wonderful okay what kind of
debt was this
124 it was student loan
debt actually Parent PLUS Loan but the
good thing about that is it was a
fraudulent school and so we were able to
get you got the money back yes well we
were able to get it forgiven completely
so incredible That's the Silver Lining
of getting a fake degree oh my gosh and
it was half that's crazy yeah yeah uh
cars yep medical Furniture my dumb
mistakes Furniture yes do you still have
the furniture no no some of it it broke
down oh gosh so it was sitting on the
curve and I cried every day I came came
home so they picked it up if you're
still paying payments on furniture that
broke down that's you're breaking down
yes I was oh my goodness all right how
did you get hooked up with this this
crazy crew of people crazy crew of
people that's us that's us that's us uh
well actually we were introduced by a
friend uh years ago and her husband
really wasn't on board so my was I
wasn't on board either no man you you
had some uh some uh foot stools some
Ottomans to buy
yeah that yeah yeah but three years ago
something clicked how did that happen to
be honest with you it was years ago we
were doing davish D yeah in and out in
and out it was like a buffet you're like
I'll take a little bit of this but I'm
going to avoid uh this piece over here
you didn't go all in but then when 2020
when the co hit we had to stop working
and just kind of like we're we're broke
we have nothing we were it made us look
at life totally different and
I told her I said well I guess I ain't
got no choice to get on board now
because we don't have nothing so she
started working it out and I started
grudgingly doing it embarrassed but I
did it and we are out of that hey okay
hold on you you blew by this I grew up
right across the line over there in
Houston okay so my guess is we got some
of similar
messages that is a hard thing to say I
broke I got to submit I want to know
what was in your heart when that was
going on cuz that that is a rare
statement coming from a tall handsome
man I had to swallow my pride and
realize hey we're in dead I mean it was
no other way out of it I mean it was
embarrassing and couldn't we had to tell
a lot of family members we can't do it
because we don't have it and you know I
just had to look her in the eye and say
baby we we're in trouble and can I tell
you like uh like I'm getting Goosebumps
here
like paying off debts awesome and I know
s Ram all that that right there I'm so
proud out of you and that sets a model
for every man sitting at home right now
whose wife doesn't know how bad it
really is and they can't breathe and so
they get loud they get mad they they
snap at their kids right there's another
way and it's you looking in the mirror
and putting both hands on that on that
on that uh counter there in the bathroom
looking in the mirror and going this
ends with me right right I'm proud of
you man that's big time that's big time
awesome so what were the Tactical steps
you guys took cuz to do this plan you
got to live on less than you make you
got to expenses you got to go make more
income what were the keys for you guys
yeah we both have four jobs between both
of us so um yeah getting extra income in
and really sitting down like he said
during coid we had a chance to just stop
and breathe and really look at our bills
and we're like man you know we we have
to start somewhere you know and and I'm
an FPU coordinator uh I also taught um I
teach foundations as as well so I knew
what to do it's just um and we had
started but like I said we were doing
davish davish and so uh when we sat down
and really really decided to we we need
to do this you know then that's when it
was Full Speed Ahead right what was the
dumbest thing y' y'all realized y'all
had payments going out to oh gosh uh it
was a television a television a wash and
dryer and other things that I say well
we need this now we'll worry about it
later and was like Wow but then when
they broke down and they sitting on the
curve waiting to be picked up oh I'm
like man that's that dude you stupid
still pay but we still paying but thing
about it was I knew she was serious when
I opened my wallet and my credit card
was gone I'm like where's my credit oh I
cut it up you you yeah no need to call
the fra Department robbed him I love it
I love it I had nothing to negotiate
with so oh you guys are incredible but
that's a big sacrifice a lot of people
they that credit card is a security
blankie right that's going to be their
Savior and what if there's an emergency
I'm like uh you just bought a TV and a
washer dryer and you live in levita Loca
let's not you don't seem too worried
about emergencies let me ask you this
question that's
amazing you've got two beautiful kids
over here right my guess is you had to
tell them no and what culture tells me
as a parent of two young kids right now
is if you say the word no your kids just
spontaneously combust and they evaporate
and they'll hate you forever they look
to be doing all right they look like
they're living and breathing right
they'll get over
it they'll get over it yeah but we we
Yeah we actually have five kids we have
three grown kids have been out of the
house uh there's the parent Plus Loans
right yes wow and I bet the
relationship's different now that those
loans are out of the way right so much
different Thanksgiving dinner is going
to be different this year tastes a lot
better W what a beautiful family we
travel better now we don't fuss now you
know cuz I'm mad because of my debt and
hope getting her all upset so we just
wow we drove up to Freeport just
cracking jokes all the way yeah well you
got I I don't know if you were this
joyful before but you sure are joyful
now yeah yeah and I hope a part of that
because you're living a peaceful life
without payments feels good that's
amazing so what do you tell tell that
couple they've been davish they know
their friends told them about Dave they
know they're listening to the show and
they're still like yeah I'm just I'm not
ready what do you tell them the key to
getting out of debt is if they're if
they're serious about it you know
definitely budgeting
that's number one to budget um but also
you know don't despise Small Beginnings
you know it's hard at the beginning to
start something new you know but once
you get going you know and just
persevere and and get through it now
when I do a budget it's just like that
it takes no time you know uh but um just
hang in there persevere and to our men I
just say swallow your pride just reality
I mean when you can tell can't tell your
wife I can't even buy buy you a rose
cuz I don't have no money for it just
swallow your pride and she did she I
swallowed my pride and it was like whoa
okay she still loves me so I'm good now
she now you can buy her several dozen
roses right he did yesterday it's our
35th Anniversary W congratulations
you're smooth too you don't owe nobody
any money and you're smooth right right
now we're eating good with and we're not
making payments on it later right well
we've got a living give box for you to
celebrate this incredible Milestone
includes baby steps millionaires The
Total Money Makeover and Financial Peace
University you can get someone else's
Journey started with that that's
exciting well let's get the kids up what
are their names and ages Christian is 13
Christina is 16 both of you guys have a
strong shoe game well done and strong
parents and you they got to watch you
guys do this stuff and we say more as
CAU and taught yeah and so they know the
sacrifice mom and dad made to set them
up for a better future well he actually
cut up our last credit card so he
definitely knows way to go Christian I
bet that felt good oh my goodness
there's the picture of them if you're
watching on YouTube that's incredible
all right here we go you guys ready
ready all right loud and proud Greg and
Kim Christina and Christian
$124,000 paid off in three years making
70 up to 108 they swallowed their pride
they got four jobs they're not fooling
around and they are dead free count it
down let's hear a debt free Scream 3 2 1
we're Deb
[Music]
[Applause]
free that put a little pep in my step
John I don't know about you dude I'm
hyped that dude's awesome that's why we
do what we do freedom is available to
you America but you got to stop being
ish you got to get serious you got to
swallow your pride you got to make the
sacrifices but it's all worth it to have
that kind of smile on your face at the
end of the day this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day comes from Acts
5:42 day after day in the temple courts
and from house to house they never
stopped teaching and proclaiming the
good news that Jesus is the Messiah Mark
Twain said don't let schooling interfere
with your education o Mark Twain burn
sick burn to the guy with two phds Mark
Twain burn I love it that's strong
strong content Mark Twain still hits I
don't care what you say he does but he
also suggested you I don't know wreck
reed every once in a while so oh
I haven't read his work just his quotes
exactly he speaks in tweets so he kind
of uh he actually doesn't he he doesn't
he writes in uh books well before
Twitter was around we had Mark Twain it
was a better time much better let's get
to the phones Mikey is in San Diego
what's going on
Mikey are you with us hey
Mikey well where there you are what US
man Hi how are you good how can we help
um so uh I recently got
married um and we've been expecting
Twins and so I'm trying to prepare for
the Twins and have like a five or seveny
year plan to to get a house I don't have
um we both combined don't have too much
in debt that I um I think we should be
able to pay it off within at least I
feel like a year or
two um
it's a I think yeah it's around 40K in
debt combined okay and what's your
household
income um so since she's working or
she's not working right now uh it's just
me it's 150 150,000 awesome great income
so why is it going to take two years to
clean up 40K making
150 um it's just because of the uh I
have a rant um that's at uh 30 it's like
3100 and then the utilities and um
whatever um I don't have a car payment
so it's pretty easy for me to like cover
all the regular bills on top of uh what
I have to try and pay down my um uh debt
but she I'm trying to get to her debt um
as fast as possible so I can help her oh
well I'm confused her debt my debt are
you guys married
oh I'm sorry my bad our Deb I'm still
getting used to it okay newly Co I
understand so the 40K in debt is both of
y'all's debt
combined yes okay and what kind of debt
is
that uh it's mostly consumer and then
her I mean our uh student loan okay how
come she's not
working uh well she's pregnant right now
so um she had to pause what she was
doing and she um left her jobs and then
she just uh qualified for um disability
so we have that coming in now is she in
poor
health no uh I mean she's pregnant with
the the twins now I'm sorry but was she
doing something that was physical that
she could no longer
do oh yes she was a massage therapist
okay I I mean I'm looking through the
glass right now at one of our people
behind the board who's pregnant and um
she's showing up kicking butt I know
every every Situation's different but I
get that man being a massage therapist
carrying twins I can't even I can't wrap
my head around that um but it might be
for a couple more months to find
something right and that's not me being
insensitive that's me just looking at
yava math problem it's a pretty tough
situation to solve especially in one of
the most expensive real estate markets
in the United States and so youall have
some dreams and you have some goals and
there's some also realities to those
dreams and goals
right yes okay so making 150k you've got
40K do you have anything in
cash in the bank no not right now I mean
um so I have some side in Investments um
I didn't want to take out of 401k
obviously I have like my own personal
investment account and then I have like
a bunch of um uh trading cards that I
used to invest into what's in the
personal investment account is that just
a non-retirement brok
account yeah uh it's like a Robin Hood
so uh there's only like seven 7,000 in
there oh only 7,000 that's a lot of
money that you use to throw the at the
debt pull right now okay we just got
done to 33 what kind of cards you
got oh uh so I got Pokemon uh you know
Yu-Gi-Oh and then another um game called
like flesh and blood I had somebody
actually call into the show the other
day that paid off their debts by selling
um Pokémon cards not even playing you
can find it on YouTube that's a real how
much money you think all of your cards
are
worth truthfully uh well I know um just
give me a ballpark five grand it's about
like I'd say 70k
$70,000 yeah um I know the Market's a
little like rough right now but it's
about 70 I'm breaking the equipment here
I'm so excited Mikey listen dude do you
do you understand that your math
equation just changed you have 7,000 in
Robin Ood you have 70,000 in trading
cards and you have 40,000 in debt let's
go back to third grade math you're about
to be father of twins twin baby
girls if I'm you I'm like well my world
just changed I'm no longer in the
trading card business I'm in the dad
business and I want to set my wife up
these kids up for the best future
possible and that means when this baby's
born we have no debt and a giant
emergency fund you got those cards for
this moment right now
and let me tell you something both
George and I are parents of young kids
the single most important investment you
can ever make from this point forward is
time time just goes away and even um if
if I found a a
20-year-old he would not trade places a
broke 20-year-old would not trade places
with Warren Buffett who has hundred
billion dollar and he's
93 why cuz a timeon
and dude you can accelerate two years of
your life by selling trading
cards you cannot get those years back
especially years with
twins I would have those cards on the
market before Sunday strikes
midnight and I'd probably sell them a
little bit undervalue just to get them
out of the house and start getting some
cash in and you will be debt free within
10 days you just bought yourself a year
you bought yourself two years your life
back cuz you just told us that man
things are tight I'm not I'm going it's
going to take me two years to get rid of
this debt or we Leap Frog this whole
thing you pay off all your debt this
week you still have 37,000 left if you
do this right that's your emergency fund
right now you're saving for for a house
starting November
15th dude yeah yeah are you going to do
any of this or are we just wasting air
right
now no I think I mean everybody's been
telling me that um what are you scared
of what are you scared of I feel well
it's because it feels like you know a
401k for me at this point because it's
so what does the trading cards I mean
having yeah you know what else used to
be stable Beanie Babies Google
that dude we don't know what if what if
Charizard gets cancelled and all of a
sudden your precious card is worth
nothing yes yeah they're going to start
cancelling Pokemon that's going to be
the new
thing okay dude you're sitting you're
sitting on two years of your life you
know what's a 401k Mikey a 401k and so
you're going to get there in no time I
would quit playing games on Robin Hood
I'd quit the trading cards you're a
grown man with twin twin baby girls
let's start acting like it and you're
going to have 150 Grand coming in with
no debt with money in the bank saved get
your kids a house your wife can stay
home if she wants to with no stress it's
it's not even a conversation cuz you
have options at that point Earl earlier
brother we did a debt free screen with
this guy named Greg and he's one of my
new Heroes and he said I asked him
what's the key and he said men swallow
your pride and do what's right this is
that moment
dude this is that
moment we did our best John we'll see if
it works It's Our Moment oh well hey
before we go I want to remind folks that
this book just launched this week I'm
really proud of it it's called Breaking
Free from broke the Ultimate Guide to
more money and less stress and you can
get it ramsy solutions.com store that'
be it' mean the world if you'd support
it and pre-order it we'll bribe you with
a $100 worth of bonus items including
the audiobook and ebook and uh means the
world John happy weekend to you my
friend congratulations on getting the
book out man thank you feels good that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
n
oh